no
you can't do i can't look directly at
your bottle it's like look at that sun
dog i can't
so dude the gathering that i was at was
the first one that was profitable that's
great man because of you dog
you straight up man you showed up and
[__] everybody got paid look at that
dude how about uh chris hansen you had
chris hanson there boys somehow oh yeah
friends with chris he texted me
merry christmas that's a cool line with
chris man i'm gonna [__] run all my
[__] like daughter's boyfriends
through them you know what i'm saying be
like yo i have a seat with chris hanson
right quick [__] you know what
i'm saying
like why don't you sit down for a second
yeah oh my god when he says interrogate
him dude
what did he do at the gathering did he
use it he was close to the stage yeah to
the stage [__] awesome
it's pretty awesome man
but he didn't show his butthole
i showed everybody my butthole and it
was the most [__]
most notable butthole that's ever been
shown on your stage maybe i
i've ran through the whole gamut of
emotions with your butthole man
straight up man your photo was like
[__] mesmerized me amazed me
that's [__]
it's like sat in the bathroom punching
the wall thinking about it
yo dude let me put it this way i don't
know who took that [__] picture
but
he needs a pulitzer prize for that
[__] folder for that [__] photo
you know yeah if anybody's in the dark
right here there's there's there's
there's a big thing
with the the juggalos when you go to the
gathering the jugglers you go to an icp
show you see jugglers anywhere it is
very important to them
that to see buttholes that's what they
think they scream for they love it they
don't show their butthole right and
they're like everybody dude show me your
baby you know everybody always wants
what's up with the butthole thing i
can't answer that i don't know i don't
know how they're passionate about it
i've never showed my butthole they
really want to see everybody
they really like they're not prejudiced
against the butthole they don't know who
the butthole's on right if it's dirty
clean right they don't give a [__] just
like that you show a butthole after
after the gathering of the juggalos i
started i had a [__] butthole beauty
pageant at uh at at one of my shows what
a good idea yeah tears you you had to i
was you i mean the title no
i didn't actually enter i i showed
everybody
you know i showed everybody but but uh
but it's interesting so so i'm hosting
the gathering juggalos and i'm like they
want to see my butthole who am i to not
to withhold this thing that they want so
i showed my butthole
and because of the lighting maybe like i
spread it as wide as i could that was
probably a factor because people were
talking about this on the way here yeah
like we were like was he like trying to
[__] or something i was just like
no i think i think that people aren't
used to seeing buttholes with the cheeks
spread that
i think the lighting was just so perfect
dude i pulled them apart as until it
hurt i pulled my butt cheeks apart that
had to hurt yeah and so this fake this
picture coming and now i see like inside
of your large right it was cavernous yes
it was absolutely like taverns
underneath [__] right
now dude
so you text me this photo the day after
the gathering and i'm like i text it to
my girl and she goes dude what the [__]
man you could fit the entire head of the
microphone in that gaping [__] you
know like why do you have a game i
couldn't believe what i was seeing i
know i couldn't believe it either i was
like wow
and then you
you came back okay i just heard the
crowd go ape [__] you know what i'm
saying right and then he comes back and
he goes yo man i couldn't just ride my
my ass as hard as i could
you know what i'm saying
yeah and then yo i get
and here's the thing dude like i have
this like
this relief
that that i know if anybody googles
stevo's butthole then thank god i've got
a a
like popular brand of hot sauce called
stevo's hot sauce for your butter yeah
so like you're gonna go you're gonna get
thousands of pages of just [__] about my
hot sauce you need to use that for the
label
i
because it's probably it's normally like
a rhetorical request
you know what i'm saying like if like if
i wasn't sitting here and laughing with
my body i might be concerned like yo you
might want to get that [__] you might
hurt somebody
yeah taking a mandingo or something yeah
you might want to see a doctor about
that that's uh
so i i started this uh this email list
as well as this uh like uncensored page
i i didn't put it on my uncensored page
yet i'm waiting to kind of tell the
story of my butthole but but but on my
email list
i'll tell you i'm with you i'll i'll
take it i'll have a journey with you i
would love that i would like to feel
like i'm a part of it a little bit you
are and and we can keep we can use this
this footage to help tell the story hey
man what we have to talk about the
camera and here goes steve stevo's
butthole for your viewing pleasure
i mean dude dude
let's let's check in are we gonna see it
right now
no
you can't do i can't look directly at
your bottle it's like look at that sun
dog i can't please don't show me your
butter
i'm gonna
okay i just wanted to prove to you that
that it's not my god
what
i was going to try to prove that that
it's not actually gaping that it was
just the lightning
right but did i send a mass email
and it's crazy like this email list is
in mass just so you know yeah dude
like it's crazy with that with it and by
the way every single email comes
absolutely from me
and and i have analytics to see how many
people opened it and five thousand
people oh i sent it to my mass emailed
it
i was like guys my butthole is uh is
something of legend and and and
yeah
legend of the lord i think of war yeah
it's blown out
yeah it looks like
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never been allowed to do for jackass and
a lot of it is flagrantly illegal so
it's adults only and if you live in any
of these states then you better go to
stevo.com and check out my tour schedule
hurry up and get your tickets too
because it's selling out everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]